the huge Nova kakov kadams seen by
satellite before its breach and after
almost completely overwhelmed or Swept
Away
suddenly the terrain of War across a
swathe of Southern Ukraine looks
completely different a potential
Battleground now under millions of
gallons of water at what could be a
pivotal moment
the breach of the dam has flooded one of
the most crucial fault lines of this
wall that runs the length of the danipra
river
in August Russian forces retreated from
land they taken north of the river to a
new defensive line along it and dug in
in trenches and fortifications on and
south of its Southern Bank in locations
marked here with red spots
it's not clear how flooded those
defenses are but the river itself is now
an even bigger obstacle for ukrainians
to cross
this temporarily at least greatly
advantages the Russians Ukraine is quite
clearly it's beginning it's
counter-offensive and it's got a lot of
choices about where it attacks the rise
in waters the flood will make it more
difficult for the ukrainians to attack
across the river the breach comes after
this a marked increase in fighting in
Ukraine over the last few days is this
the start of Ukraine's counter-offensive
it's not clear but if it is then Russia
May well be taking pre-emptive action at
enormous cost again to the people who
live here
and there's this to worry about too the
waters held back by the dam are used to
cool the nuclear rods in Europe's
biggest nuclear power station at
zapparesia the world's nuclear Watchdog
the iaea says it's watching the
situation closely
the war has taken another Lurch in an
unexpected Direction with many more no
doubt to come Dominic wagorn Sky News